for the first time in his two years in
office President Joe Biden landed in the
epicenter of the crisis on America's
Southern border
as he surveyed areas overwhelmed by
migrants Republicans called it too
little too late it just so happens he's
two years at about 20 billion dollars
too late
he needs to step up and and take Swift
action the president spoke with local
state and federal leaders and assessed
security at the bridge of the Americas
the busiest border crossing in El Paso
now the center of the migrant crisis
this is one of the many sites President
Biden didn't see hundreds of migrants
living in the streets throughout El Paso
with no end in sight
Raphael has been sleeping inside a box
to protect him from near freezing
overnight temperatures hoping for what
American citizens take for granted
My ultimate goal is to get a work permit
so I can do what I came here to do to
work hard I would ask President Biden to
find a solution to this because what we
want is work he's among hundreds who
live indefinitely Outdoors ducking into
humanitarian buses for warmth and a
phone charge dining on donated meals
their children playing in the chaos as
they do on both sides of the Border
at Sacred Heart Catholic Church Father
Rafael Garcia takes in 150 lucky
migrants each night many of the rest
live out here they've adjusted and
thanks thanks be to God it's not too uh
to call right now the temperatures are
not going below freezing the past few
days I'm forecasted to not go free below
freezing in the next few days from what
I know so it's it's uh the climate is
cooperating but it's still a harsh
situation to be on the streets yeah
there needs to be a national solution
right a national solution they cannot
expect the local government to resolve
these problems a solution the U.S
government has left undone for decades
even as Biden calls for comprehensive
immigration reform after his first on
the ground look at the migrant crisis
the president left to meet with the
Canadian Prime Minister and the Mexican
president in Mexico City where he hopes
to find progress on the border crisis
the U.S hasn't found in Washington John
hendren Al Jazeera El Paso Texas